[Musique]
j'ai trente avant je suis bien roulé un
peu d'eau
de l'eau chauffée par tes belles cuisses
non merci ça ira remercie paul
compliment nous sommes en direct avec la
grande chef chasseral et compliance et
brandon folle c'est une très belle cause
san francisco qui va ouvrir un nouveau
restaurant dans deux mois j'ai besoin
que tu sois là bas
[Applaudissements]
salut salut marcus salut salut sacha
salue enfin ça fait longtemps
[Musique]
oui c'est vrai ça fait longtemps ça
boume sacha demi situer notre oprah
zietek dubois combien d'argent tu gagnes
il est sérieux je suis étonné que vous
ayez perdu contact tous les deux vous
étiez si proche avant alors qu'est ce
que tu comptes faire avec brandon est
parti ce matin en inde n'a le droit
d'aller voir ailleurs il le fait pour le
bien de notre cocon plus je me suis
enfin rendu compte que je ne vais pas me
marier
j'arrive pas à croire que j'ai gâché mes
années les plus fertiles avec toi je
suis en fait rendu compte un peu moins
fort s'il vous plaît vous à les effrayer
la chèvre
[Musique]
je crois qu'il va falloir que je me
mette à voir d'autres mecs qu'elle
galère vous êtes chou avec marquez non
non quoi vous ne vous êtes jamais mis en
scène un lourd passif entre huit mois
ouf
dans mon corps ta ville corps l'ars
qu'est-ce que tu regarde maman kataria
c'est parce qu'on n'y a fait l'amour non
ça te fait quoi
eh ben elle est beaucoup plus petit et
beaucoup plus crade que dans mon
souvenir j'espère vraiment que tu parles
de ma banque est
[Musique]
ne pose pas trop de questions
mais ce que tu ressens j'ai une super
nouvelle oui la mienne est bien aussi
non moi d'abord j'ai rencontré un mec
super j'ai passé une des nuits
c'était complètement dingue j'suis pas
trop juste il aime étaler sur ce genre
et vous conduit
le voilà
[Musique]
granomor moddeurs maman que ton corps
m'a manqué ton coeur m'a manqué tous
maman qui adore ce que tu fais avec des
pouces
[Musique]